all the hunters you're about to meet
have one thing in common
they all use teamwork
they communicate
they strategize
they ambush
all for the sake of the kill
these are the world's deadliest
predators
and they gang up in packs and swarms
[Music]
of all the group hunters on earth these
are among the biggest
in their african homeland
lions sit at the top of the food chain
females do most of the hunting
[Music]
while males rest and protect territory
to survive
lions rely on teamwork
[Music]
a time-tested strategy
will be used against the warthogs
one female will get as close as possible
[Music]
and then drive the prey to another
lurking in ambush
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
lions have great vision
the brightest sunshine won't blind them
and in low light they can see six times
better than humans
they can hear prey from a mile away
and their sense of smell is so keen they
can tell how recently the prey passed
lions will take on prey more than twice
their size
a full-grown zebra can weigh nearly half
a ton
[Music]
[Music]
one kick from those hoofs can break a
lion's jaw
lions are sprinters
not marathoners
they can hit 35 miles an hour
but only for a few seconds
so they team up approaching their prey
from different angles
zebras learned to keep their distance
but one zebra is about to violate the
first rule of the safari
always stay with the group
[Music]
the lion will go for the typical death
blow
crushing the windpipe
while the team keeps their prey from
getting away
of all the world's cats
lions are the only social animal
especially at dinner time
after a kill is made males always eat
first
then the females
what's left goes to the cubs
often not enough
most will not survive into adulthood
lions need up to 15 pounds of food per
day
so for the pride to endure
they have to keep on the hunt
but some prey calls for the whole team
cape buffalo are truly big game
one lion can be outweighed five to one
by a buffalo
to take it down the lionesses need
reinforcement
the pride's male could weigh twice as
much as a female
there's no random gang up it's a
two-pronged attack
distract the buffalo
then go for the hind quarters to bring
it down
but even africa's biggest cats
can't always eat in peace
[Music]
someone out there wants to mooch their
meal
few creatures would dare confront a
proud lioness
but few creatures are as bold as a pack
of hyenas
this kind of fight has rarely been
filmed
like a humble house cat the lioness
takes refuge in a tree
proof that a whole pack
trumps one queen
[Music]
as tough as hyenas might be
their culture more closely resembles
monkeys than lions
hyenas live in clans that can reach as
large as 80.
unlike lions they have a matriarchal
hierarchy
a female is always the chief
below females are cubs
and at the bottom of the social order
are adult males
within each group
there are strict levels of rank
not determined by size or strength
but by its mother's status
the most fortunate cub is born to the
chief of the clan
hyenas are notorious scavengers and will
steal kill from bigger predators
like this leopard
vultures tip off the hyenas
there's fresh meat to be had
and the hyenas grab it
can the leopard recover its fumble
when a hunter gets its prize
it eats what it can
until the clan starts to arrive
then it gives up its spot and leaves
higher ranking females to the choice
cuts
yes they're good thieves
but also good hunters
among the most prolific predators in
africa
today on the open plains of the
serengeti their strategy is simple
form a semi-circle around this herd of
wildebeest
and pick off stragglers
[Music]
lions kill their prey before consuming
them
but hyenas eat their prey alive
blessed with powerful jaws and a cast
iron stomach
they can crush and digest bone
the calcium from within the bone turns
the hyenas feces white
[Music]
and they're the only carnivore that eats
hides
hair and horns go to waste
it can eat up to one-fifth its weight in
one sitting
and it can eat rotten flesh so it buries
leftovers for later
out here hyenas are one mob that grazers
don't want to run into
[Music]
but if any predators deserve to be
called a mob it's the meerkats of south
africa
and that's just what they are called a
mob
20 is a typical size
but some mobs number more than 40.
meerkats aren't cats
these mammals belong to the mongoose
family
they hunt as a pack
but before they can go on offense
they have to mount a defense
the reason is simple
at only about two pounds and just a foot
long meerkats are vulnerable to other
predators
so for protection one member finds a
termite mound or shrub and keeps watch
if the sentry spots trouble he'll bark
he'll be relieved in about an hour so he
too can forage
meantime he constantly gives the meerkat
signal for all clear
with the lookout posted the rest of the
mob can come out of their burrow and
hunt
they hunt small mammals like this
squirrel
not always with success
insects and scorpions are dietary
staples too
they'll team up to turn over rocks and
help each other dig
its fingers are tipped with curved claws
nearly an inch long
the prize inside the box
scorpion
[Music]
the sting would kill a young human
but the tiny meerkat is immune
[Music]
it bites off the scorpion's tail leaving
nothing else to waste
[Music]
like meerkats
these predators don't look like a
menacing mob
[Music]
humpbacks are known as the ocean's
gentle giants
tell that to its prey
the humpbacks are setting the stage for
a massacre
[Music]
humpbacks can look gentle
as watching a mother with calf proves
[Music]
they feed mainly in summer
and live off their fat in winter
their commute to their feeding ground is
the longest known migration of any
mammal
up to ten thousand miles round trip
humpbacks are generally loners
but they'll come together to hunt
southeast alaska
[Music]
these humpbacks are about to net
thousands of fish
[Music]
they used two tactics that in the hands
of a child would be harmless
singing and blowing bubbles
but with humpbacks the combination is
lethal
on one side of the shoal of fish
one whale creates a wall of bubbles
[Music]
on the opposite side of the shoal
another whale sounds the battle cry
the famous song of the humpback
except now the song becomes a dirge
180 decibels equal to a rocket launch
and powerful enough to damage human ears
the fish flee from the uproar
and collide with the wall of bubbles
they see the bubbles as a barrier
while they're blocked the blower swims
around them
surrounding them in a bubbly prison
with no other way out they head for the
surface to escape
right where the whale wants them
[Music]
in this ring of death dozens of
humpbacks will feast
they have no teeth so they swallowed
their prey whole
and if any creature should be nicknamed
jaws
it's the humpback
[Music]
it can spread its jaws more than 13 feet
wide and swallow hundreds of fish in one
gulp
its throat and chest are lined with 30
wide ventral grooves allowing it to open
its mouth as wide as possible to take in
hundreds of gallons of water swimming
with prey
they may eat like this twice a day
during the feeding season
humpbacks aren't the only horde with a
famous call
[Music]
the call of the wild can chill your
bones
especially if it's the last sound you'll
ever hear
[Music]
their hal is an all-purpose telegraph
it summons members marks borders and
sends warnings
but this coyote didn't get the message
to keep out
[Music]
wolves don't like having their meals
mooched
[Music]
[Music]
like hyenas and lions there is a strict
hierarchy within each pack
however with wolves
the highest ranking status goes to a
couple
the alpha male and female
they always eat first and only they will
bear young
the other members of the pack will help
raise their cubs
after six weeks pups need more than
their mother's milk
they need meat to survive
too young to join the hunt
the pop will stay behind in the den
if the adults are successful
they will regurgitate the kill for the
young when they return
but getting that meat isn't always easy
a single wolf packs territory averages
80 square miles in size
wolves have scent glands in their toes
so as they trap prey they leave messages
behind for fellow pack members
they have a highly developed sense of
smell and in the right conditions can
detect scents from almost two miles away
prey might be tracked for hours or days
before the pack starts its chase
the longest recorded pursuit stretched
for 13 miles
no wonder the deadly german subs of
world war ii were called wolf packs
legend tells of humans raised by wolves
[Music]
but this pack hunter
is your own next of kin
chimpanzees
they share more than 98 of our dna
that makes them our closest cousin
[Music]
chimps were once considered strict
vegetarians
[Music]
but not anymore
they're one of nature's most cunning
killers
in some parts of africa a chimp will eat
a ton of meat a year
like us they have complex sounds for
communicating
[Music]
this chimp gives the signal
that it's time to hunt
hunting parties like this one may hold
up to three dozen members
and their search could last up to four
hours
they hunt 25 species including small
antelope and wild pigs
but they've found their favorite prey
red calabas monkeys
[Music]
here's where brainpower pays off
[Music]
they take positions in the treetops
surrounding the monkeys
[Music]
with the escape routes cut off
the real hunt is about to begin
[Music]
male monkeys will actually fight back
but it's david versus goliath without
the slingshot
the chimp outweighs it six to one
youngsters and mothers are split up
leaving easy pickings
chimps have sharp teeth but to kill prey
chimps use gravity hurling their prey
with lethal force against a hard surface
half a dozen monkeys might be killed in
a single attack
but usually just one
big males dominate the group so they eat
first just like the lions
unlike lions and like humans
males share their meal with family and
allies
the next predator could hunt just fine
on its own but as a pack it takes on
prey
10 times its size
south america
has more than 20 species of piranha
the most notorious is the red-bellied
piranha
and they're about to earn their
reputation
[Applause]
in the rainy season rivers crest their
banks and flood the land
piranha follow
the rain brings a bumper crop
of prey
great white egrets
nesting in the only dry place left
awkward young egrets aren't ready to fly
so if they lose their balance they're
goners
like sharks
piranha have sensors to detect other
creatures movements
[Music]
once blood is shed
piranha can detect a drop from two miles
away
thrashing only draws more piranha
all that's left is pillow stuffing
their name comes from two native words
pira meaning fish and anna meaning teeth
and no wonder
their teeth are triangular
interlocking and dense
and so sharp they can cut a steel
fishing line
but the fish with the monstrous
reputation is actually small
on average about as long as a pencil
so piranhas school for the same reason
other fish do
safety in numbers
when rivers are high food is plentiful
but beware the dry season
as the land dries out
rivers retreat into oxbows and ponds
confined to a natural fishbowl
piranha will go after anything they can
sink their teeth in
injured piranha are quickly cannibalized
as for those legendary attacks on humans
rare
and no one has ever documented a human
being killed by a piranha attack
from over-hyped legend to undisputed
fact
the fastest animal on land
the cheetah
cheetahs hunt by vision
not by scent
like commandos
they sport black marks on the inside
corner of each eye
perhaps to cut the sun's glare
everything about a cheetah is designed
for the chase
it gains traction from claws that don't
retract
and paw pats with extra grip
it'll try to creep within 100 feet from
its target before bursting into action
clocked as fast as 71 miles per hour
at top speed it takes about three and a
half strides every second
and every minute up to 150 breaths
its hind legs are so flexible
they can pass the front ones
and for almost half the time at full
speed
the legs don't even touch earth
female cheetahs hunt alone
but males hunt in packs
males like these are usually brothers
and they usually bond for life
working as a pack they can tackle bigger
prey
like these wildebeests
and when the brothers are hungry
not even a little bad weather will slow
them down
the ferrari of animals
able to accelerate from zero to 60 in
three seconds
but its temperature soars so high
if it doesn't stop after 300 yards it
could die
but that's why it's in a pack
[Music]
two more with fresh legs
once they bring the wildebeest down
the cheetahs choke it to death
a truly lethal band of brothers
another predator keeps on the move in
its constant search for food
orcas
the killer whales
every day
they eat up to 300 pounds of prey
[Music]
and peninsula valdez in argentina stocks
a banquet
seals
deep water and steep beaches make an
ideal hunting ground
to find prey orcas use built-in sonar
called echolocation
they send out clicks and whistles that
bounce off the target
and because of the steep slope at this
beach
anorca can swim under the cover of a
wave
all the way to shore
[Music]
mothers will take prey back to the open
water and turn it loose
so their offspring can learn to hunt
what looks like playing with their food
is actually a seminar
in predation
[Music]
[Music]
orcas are the largest member of the
dolphin family and an apex predator of
the sea
hunted by no other creature
orcas will team up to grab prey that
seems out of reach
like an arctic seal at rest
working in tandem the orcas cause a
fatal dunking
they live in pods up to 40 strong
communicating through whistles and
grunts
unique to their pod
[Music]
warp speed is about 30 miles an hour
about every 30 seconds they surface to
breathe
the pod detects big game
gray whales
but it's the calf thereafter
they have a two-pronged strategy
first force the gray whales to swim
faster and tire the calf
then separate calf from mother
the orcas will dunk the calf till it
weakens and drowns
[Music]
this marathon of torment lasts almost
six hours
nature has given prey a host of defenses
from strength
to speed
to camouflage
but if there's one pack of predators who
have managed to stack the deck in their
favor
it's the hunters that live here
the painted dogs named for their
uniquely colored coats
no relation to the hyenas these are the
so-called wild dogs of africa
maybe the most successful hunters on
earth
four out of five chases end in a kill
their attack starts with a charge to
stampede prey and reveal weaklings
for the takedown they have no weapon
except their teeth
but they have large premolars for
crushing and eating bones
and their bite is among the strongest of
any meat-eating mammal
[Applause]
they're not born as first-class hunters
their skills are actually learned
adults regurgitate meat for pups but
painted dogs are so social they share
food with the sick and the old
they seldomly show aggression to each
other
rare behavior in the natural world
painted dogs hunt across a spectrum of
terrain
from savannah
to bush
to flood plain
when prey is trapped the dogs enjoy the
advantage of a 360 degree attack
a tactic that sooner or later wears down
the defender
they've honed a technique to protect
themselves from the lethal horns of
african game
as one holds prey by the tail another
pins it by the mouth
the rest go for the guts and eat it
alive
they have no choice
lurking lions would steal their meal
so they wolf it down in minutes and in
silence
unlike hyenas who can't dine without
raising a fuss and drawing a crowd
[Music]
the highest complement to this pack
comes from its very prey
the lek
way lekway head for deep water when
threatened
the lekway are still in hot water
once caught few victims escape from
these jaws
what a tribute to these predators
that their prey fears them more than
they fear crocs
strength in numbers
nature's gift to a host of predators
who thrive by sticking together
for those who think a committee never
gets anything done
just ask these guys
[Music]
[Music]
you